hmm now I am like senpai hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome back
to uni camstudio now we're back in our
little empire here and we've got a whole
bunch of fun to be had a lot of money to
be made for me and for them even though
I kind of tricked him with a piggy bank
into the point where they're not really
asking for a lot more money but that's
that's besides the point then that's
entirely their fault like I didn't do
any of that they got the piggy bank and
then they decided that they needed to be
paid less I didn't have anything to do
with it
so enough justification about my shitty
business practice this is on my own time
to talk to virtual girls actually they
don't even talk to me and no one really
talks to me anyway but we have a lot of
work to be doing and I am actually
starting to go low on alcohol because
Lola I didn't need to pull up the name I
knew the name Lola it was already up
don't worry about it I got it Lola is
gonna get a butt plug was getting a butt
plug and then Keanu is gonna get the
microphone and then uh Tiffany is gonna
get the shopping bag because she's gonna
be my errand girl for like the entirety
of this so anyway so they're doing all
that stuff and then I'm doing this stuff
we get the photo shoes going on but now
Tiffany basically I sometimes feel bad
about things but I don't feel too bad
about this I just kind of need her to go
do things for me I need someone to be
able to go to get things that's
important that's a thing that people do
kind of maybe I waste money on that cuz
I got too many of these in the way ah
yes please can you go back for more we
need a lot of booze Lola is a bit of a
drinker and later in the game you're
gonna get a lot of ladies that do drink
a lot and that is a problem because that
gets in the way of a lot of other things
we need to do oh no but Tiffany can't be
my errand girl she's good at stripping I
mean is so so creepy everything that I'm
doing
oh god just wait till I start sending
them to the sleazy motel that's gonna be
nice everyone's gonna be happy about
that but they're gonna be safe on I
didn't mention that I'm not wearing my
glasses because I was just recording on
the vibes not the vivre because god I
want to pronounce everything the wrong
way
I still call this huniepop even though
it's very obviously honey pop or cam
it's not even honey Poppins
honey honey cam it's honey cam it's
always gonna be honey cam no one's gonna
change it from being honey cam that is
just what it is and what it's always
gonna be for the rest of my existence
but for now we're still trying to run an
empire here and we've got a long way to
go because this game ends when you hit
21 days and when you hit 21 days you
better have as many fans as you're gonna
have and that includes a lot of work
because holy crap there's so many things
oh nots oh i got it it's okay it's fine
soon we're gonna be out of business
oh it's fine don't worry about it I got
it let me smooth it over for over 24
hours I'm gonna have to let you go oh
come on you can't be like that I'm good
for the money you just gotta trust me
okay I know I know what I've been doing
I haven't been getting on I haven't been
getting Nicki my moneymaker into the cam
studio and I haven't gettin a lot of him
into the camps to D because I have been
waiting off I'm doing that because I
want the value to go up on only specific
people which means that you are yeah you
need to go to the boutique I need to do
bromo I don't have money for that I
forgot okay so as soon as Nicki's out of
the photo shoot I got to get her back
into the cam studio to do more Let's
Plays even though I promised that I was
gonna be honest about that it still lets
plays everybody harsh it's nothing bad
she needs the second item as well she
needs the subscribe pillow because
that's gonna help her get more fans
continually cuz now I'm just gonna keep
her in the cam studio and then she's
just gonna go in over and over again and
I need to get the money out of it and
then she Lola you better low
better have oh if Lola doesn't have oh
just Lola have a piggy bank okay go
I forgot Lola has a piggy bank and a
butt plug everything uh young
entrepreneurial girl needs well it plugs
in piggy bank I'm gonna move on I got
more money finally I'm out of the red so
that's good because I'm out of the red
7:00 a.m. which means that I got a lot
of potential to do this and so as they
are getting more and more fans I'm gonna
send her to a strip club
I find the tip times are getting dated
they're gonna take it on camera how many
times do I need to it business before
it's okay to myself it's okay
everything's fine okay we got enough
money here so we can finally get more
fans free squirting tattoos and chubby
oh boy the kids close your eyes close
your ears close everything you have it's
not it's not appropriate I gotta get
more money out of this it takes so much
time okay yeah Nicky's making so much
money for me and that's great about it I
got to go into I got to go into super
click mode because we need to get out of
here and then I need to get more more
cash I can't believe I have to spend
cash just to be able to get my cash out
of the cash place it's such [ __ ]
down to cash full yeah ok then Lola is
waiting Lola is doing wonderfully but
Lola needs more fans before I can start
putting her in the cam shows because the
cam shows progressively mid take more
time I said that in the last one it is
true I wouldn't lie to you guys even
though I obviously lied to you guys in
the last one but don't worry about that
that's not important happy to have it
too heavy to have it to have it to have
it happen to have it have it have it
have it okay there we go someone's
relaxing okay so you argue a I need to
get these out of here before you can do
your thing
hey hey it's a good amount of money but
it's not enough money you need more fans
we need to buy more fans goddammit we
can't get more fans we need to get more
fans Aphrodite
wait books how much do I owe you guys
I'll pay off right now so that I don't
have to worry about it later okay photo
shoot the stupid I had the photo shoot
click harder oh not enough clicking not
enough time see this is a problem I get
I get I get an all in a tizzy well they
need to do these things oh man when did
she get four and four that snug
thirty-two dollars an hour for Lola
goddamn it
get alot of fans for that okay I got a
like I got I'm gonna bench Lola she's
gonna be on the back burner for a while
because I I accidentally got her up to
four and four which is definitely not
what I meant to do if anything I need to
get Niki up to another avenue of strip
strip full strip polling strip pole and
insta doing don't worry about it it's
fine at least you're getting more
fancier then I just need to basically
get all of her all of her work is gonna
be off of getting fans from the internet
and that's gonna be the main priority of
it but first Oh cake oh my god ah if
anyone didn't know the cake supports the
cake farting fetish and I don't know
about you guys I would like to keep my
innocence for just a little bit longer
not have to worry about that but
everyone's gotta grow up sometime so
we're gonna get a cake and then
someone's gonna be doing the cake
farting cake birds I mean ah you know I
didn't even I didn't even watch that
video until it was mentioned on game
grumps I knew about the video don't get
me wrong I'm not that innocent I knew
about the video very easily but the only
problem was I didn't watch it until
after I was watching the game grumps
talk about it and they built it up in my
mind that it was like some really
Midwestern accent like like yeowch cake
farts let's get this done so I was
building it up in my mind that it was
gonna be something a lot funnier than it
actually was and just turned out to be
very gross kids don't even don't even
look any of this up
now we're starting to make good money
but we got to make a lot more than this
we got to make a lot more now is the
money rush because now officially the
fans have outpaced getting him on our
own so getting him on our own doesn't
even matter I have a good thing about
Nikki doing cam shows is that she gets
extra special bonuses and then
eventually they'll have more items and
then fans'll like overlap more with the
different decided then hopefully funded
will be appropriate for people to
understand anyway gotta get more gotta
get more to make more yeah yeah yeah
yeah click harder god you look better
calculate Roger touch click okay Kiana
you need to get oh [ __ ] what do you need
to do you need to recruit another
because we're gonna need another person
in here very soon Tiffany go back into
the shop and they're great we're making
so much money get that dad okay there's
dammit stop stressing Nicky it's fine
you're just showing your boobs to
everybody on the internet it's totally
cool don't worry about it fine okay go
go go yeah I know I know I know I know I
know I know more more more you need Matt
you need to relax I guess ah come on
hurry up with the relaxing we got work
to do you gotta show your boobs to
everybody on the internet very important
ah the fairy lady is gonna be dawn my
ass dawns you're gonna dawn my ass real
good if you don't hurry up okay we're
gonna another girl we need this team or
we need that we need the cheap ones and
then yeah that's a do okay what did you
do Lola Lola what did you do I don't
know what you did but we need more fans
but we need more money but we can
officially get another girl hello hi Oh
Ames Jessie's outfit and Belle
Oh bellies there but there's also Zoey
so he's one of the new characters that
came in this game and I don't really
know much about her
I mean her characteristics are M&E and
flat-chest in Asian chubby
I guess Indian does count as Asian milf
and chubby I never considered jessie to
be chubby but anyway the descriptions
got to be what they are it's developers
not me I'm not judging anybody but we
need to coordinate here the only problem
with Jessie is that she is addicted to
both smoking and drinking and she
consumes those very quickly but she
doesn't get stressed very much which is
also a good thing so I and she's also
already trained so I can just give her a
piggy bank and then she's gonna be
cheaper so I'm gonna do that hi Jesse
how are you doing your daughter's here
too don't think I forgot about that
weird coincident instance okay so we're
gonna give you a piggy bank and coke
we'll save the butt plug for a little
bit later and they'll worry about this
right now okay so now it's official that
she can make a lot of money okay all
right okay
I just got it okay I just got a condom
and the condom is used for being safe
and being safe is very important it is
very important very important very
important because there is a sleazy
motel over there where you can send your
girls to ah
where you can send your girls to boink
boink boink boink boink boink okay so
this is good because we got we got more
fans and the fan actually you can see in
the menu the fans have a certain
distribution it because I have been
really pushing Nikki forward she has
glasses and huge means huge fans a lot
of fans like that stuff but as I've been
buying them a lot of fans like other
things too so because Lola has a butt
plug do you like that and eventually
there will be more overlap as things go
on and then
get that taken care of that's all good
and we'll get there but for right now we
just need to worry about what we got
right here and eventually once I start
making even more money once I got so
many fans I can get rid of the pity
piggy banks because pay won't even
matter and then I can get more people on
the fans so that's like a late-game
strategy it's like I don't know why I'm
strategizing for you guys but this is
how this works this is how I think I'm
gonna get rid of this discard that and
I'm gonna give her we have yeah we have
actually have a good number of furry
furry fans so give that to Kiana she off
some more fans she'll make some more
money going into that it'll be good
it'll be good good good good good I just
got to get a lot more of this going on
here come on Tiffany we need a booze run
Tiffany
all right there we go you're done there
you go back
oh god cake ferns cake fish cake fades
might as well I guess
everyone my my goal at the end of this
is to have everyone with the cake fits
okay make it more money more money more
money and done good job getting there
make more mins make more money we need
time are many need all more money all of
the money's okay so you actually you
have a good number of fans so you can
start going in there cuz we can have
three people in there once right now mmm
clicking so good right back in there get
right back in there we need okay so
that's yeah yeah yeah let's get another
condom cuz we can always use those for
some reason nobody asked right okay
before the next day I wanted to get this
which is the new advertising slob words
gonna open up a lot of opportunities for
us
here we go more people doing a cam show
do you go back right in there alright
everything is working out wonderfully
everything is working out delightfully
okay go right back in money money money
money money it's literally all I care
about I can't even pay everybody off man
I bought a lot of upgrades so that means
that we're running low on money for this
but that's totally fine okay so you need
way more you need to get all right get
more of that piece of cake funny you
mentioned that we're gonna need you to
take this cake and go into the room and
then just you know do whatever feels
natural I suppose hmm so pretty soon we
actually need to send someone in to go
recruit another girl cuz we need one
more to join our repertoire see that
like it didn't even matter that was like
insignificant and we got a whole bunch
of potential fans here for this stuff so
we just get them all up here we
basically just want as many fans as
possible like no matter what we want
fans you about 10 hours jeez Oh too much
time you're too expensive why are you so
expensive it's not good smart move I
know thanks bro I don't know how I'm
doing I actually feel like I'm doing
very poorly cuz usually in perspective
of everything else I've been doing I can
get a good judge on how far I'm coming
along but I have a funny feeling I'm not
doing it perfectly well I'm just gonna
get her in the modeling agency so I can
have that on the way I know see the good
thing about it is is when you take time
off of them in the cam studio or them
working you can actually save money
based on how much time you chopped off
because they're paid by the hour but if
you reduce the thing down a few hours
you'll pay them less so that's good
all right so we need the three items
that's gonna be even better because now
we can start spreading out the different
items that they have even better because
she had a subscribe pillow but I'm gonna
take that off now because we don't need
that anymore
because now the number of fans that
she's gonna get from other sources is
always gonna be better so yeah so it
looks like bondage is the next big one
so I'm gonna do that I guess then I'll
just give her your Nicki you can have a
butt plug to have fun with that good
luck take luck and have luck have luck
to take luck you already got those who
you need something else uh alright you
get it you get a cake I don't know how
many cake [ __ ] we have here but it's
gonna be good enough okay so that is all
the time after this episode we're making
a good bit of progress we're got a few
like we have 12 days left so I know we
can get to the end of this before
everything goes horribly tits up not in
a good way so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always see you
in the next video